which are bigger valorant Maps or CS
maps and more importantly does it
actually matter after weeks of research
I finally found answers to both these
questions let's get into it
[Music]
before we get into it I would like to
thank our friends over at Shopify for
sponsoring today's video for those that
are living under a rock Shopify is the
driving force behind Shopify Rebellion
Shopify is an organization that truly
cares about Esports and actually invests
in the spaces with state-of-the-art
facilities and Tech to bring the
absolute best out of incredible teams
and players and that same commitment is
shared with the shop app it's the best
place to discover and shop for Brands
you love making your shopping experience
easy and enjoyable whether you're
looking for an AI assistant Shopper to
help you pick out the perfect gift or
just an easy way to shop and track your
purchases the shop app has got you
covered the shop app will also
personalize your shopping experience so
that you'll see stuff you haven't even
thought about but will definitely love
just look how easy it is to find some
Shopify Rebellion merch on the app and
you can track the shipping and delivery
process step by step so you know exactly
when your stuff is coming check out the
shop up and of course pick up one of our
touchgrass hoodies visit go.shop.app the
score Esports and happy shopping alright
so it's no secret that valorent and
Counter-Strike share more than a few
similarities but nowhere are there
differences more apparent than in map
design where CS is open and flowy
Valerian is considerably more intimate
at least that's how it feels you see
there are a lot and I mean a lot of
Threads Online discussing how small
valorant maps are and more recently I've
started to see people compare them
directly to what CS has to offer now
while I'd normally chalk the size NV up
to self-esteem issues I do think it's an
interesting conversation especially
considering some of valorin's gameplay
designs I mean to be honest the game can
be a chaotic mess sometimes but
our valorent Maps actually smaller I
need more than just feelings I need cold
hard facts so with the help of my trusty
sidekick Magoo we embarked on a journey
to uncover the truth once and for all
and our conclusions might just shock you
now I already do you know what you're
wondering how do you compare map sizes
into different video games using two
different engines that you know aren't
real physical places well it turns out
while conducting our investigation it's
complicated
and to be honest we hit a few walls
along the way now the first big hurdle
we face when trying to find accurate
square meters is figuring out a scale
that can work in both games if you use
the Ping feature in valorant you can see
that it measures in meters which is
great if we assume that valorant meters
are the same as real meters calculating
the surface area would be actually
pretty simple you just divide the map up
into rectangles length times with those
puppies and then add all the
measurements and Bob's your uncle
unfortunately Counter-Strike is much
more complicated since this is valve and
they need to make everything difficult
The Source engine actually has their own
unit of measurement
Hammer units Hammer units which have
their own wiki page by the way are used
to measure things in pretty much every
title that uses source and as a result
plenty of creators have used this to
compare Maps amongst the games now there
is a conversion for Hammer units to real
world measurements but this would only
work if the scaling and Counter-Strike
made any sense whatsoever player models
are supposed to be roughly six feet tall
in Counter-Strike but as many people
have shown over the years these short
kings are either lying about their
height or in cs's World doorways are
nine feet tall and European Coupes are
actually very spacious trucks for that
reason we had to go down a different
path and what made most sense to us was
finding an object in each game that is
the same height as the player this is
because in both games player height is
consistent regardless of agent then we
convert the object we find in
Counter-Strike over to valorent and
scale it to match the object we find in
valorant and that's because valorent
uses real-life meters and not made up
like Hammer units once again Riot made
this very simple radio night boxes which
exist on every map app are all two by
two by two meters and the same height as
the player models which side note yes
this means that Valor and agents are
like six six obviously it's for hitboxes
to remain consistent but it goes against
like all the lore and I just think it's
funny to point out anyway we had our
radiant eye boxes and although it was
more difficult we were able to find
something pretty close in CS this
beautiful pile of cardboard boxes
neither are perfect but hey this isn't
an exact science the point is we had our
scales and was finally time to map out
the square meters of every map but since
I'm stupid this was left in very capable
hands of Magoo first he ported over the
game files of each map into blender
which fun fact turns out you can do in
both games then we grab the scales from
CS brought it over to valorent and
matched it with the ready night boxes we
got there as it turns out CS is roughly
one-third the size of valorent in
blender so multiply everything by 2.7
and suddenly everything matches now we
use blender's measuring tools in an
orthographic top-down view to find
reference points we then Port those map
overview files into illustrator and
match the scales once again finally we
trace the map footprint non-playable
area and overlapping areas before
plugging it into a handy dandy script
that calculates the playable area in
square meters now at this point we had a
crisis of faith we finally had our
numbers but we've never done anything
like this before so we felt like we
needed a second set of eyes so we
reached out to Lydia zanotti an actual
3D environmental artist who worked on
maps in both these games and we asked if
our methodology even made any sense I
mean I think I would probably do it that
way too you heard it here first folks
mean Magoo aren't complete morons and
that's all we needed to hear so now we
can give you the numbers alright so it
turns out surprise surprise CS maps are
in fact larger than valorence however
the difference isn't that massive from
the maps that we had time to calculate
overpass is the largest map in
Counter-Strike and by no surprise Breeze
is the biggest invalent however the
difference in the playable areas of both
these Maps is just under 700 square
meters that being said Counter-Strike
does have much more variation when it
comes to their map sizes ancient the
smallest map we've recorded so far is 40
smaller than overpass in contrast the
playable area for Valor Maps other than
Breeze averages at roughly 6 500. I feel
like it was more of a process a riot
there's more level designers there's a
whole team of map designers whereas
valve you know has one level designer
and maybe one person working on one map
one person working on another so there
is inconsistency but as far as all these
valorant maps go I'm I'm honestly not
surprised that the number averages
around 6 500 or so still if we look at
the maps that are comparable in size in
both games the difference isn't that
massive and if we do what I like to call
the field test we get similar results if
I roughly run around the perimeter of
the two largest Maps I do a complete lap
about 10 seconds faster on Breeze sure
depending on how you look at it 10
seconds or 700 square meters could be a
big distance but it's not nearly as bad
as how people make it out to be online
but I don't blame people for having this
gut reaction hell Lydia herself worked
on these maps and admits to having this
instinctual sense of feeling cramped in
valorant yeah I don't know the numbers
but to me I do feel like The Valor maps
are smaller even when you take a map
like Haven that has three whole bomb
sites it's pretty small and straight
forward there are some gimmicks in some
of the maps like on Ascent where you can
shut a door and that kind of slows you
down and it kind of helps with the small
Map size however Lydia and everyone else
who feels this way aren't wrong Valor
maps are smaller just not always in the
literal sense first off yes certain
agents have abilities that allow them to
close distances very quickly on top of
that valorent map designs are incredibly
claustrophobic thanks to the sheer
amount of angles in indoor spaces on
every map but as some people have
pointed out it's actually a single
gameplay design that trumps all in
Counter-Strike you are Frozen to where
you spawn until the match timer starts
in valrant you are free to walk around
anywhere in your designated buy Zone
which on defense is over half the map
not only does this reduce the time it
takes to walk to a site but it means
that interactions can happen almost
instantaneously you can get taken out of
a round the moment it starts as a result
it also means that the majority of
gunfights happen in a much smaller
portion of the entire playable area
making Maps feel underutilized and even
repetitive which is something that
valerian's current senior technical game
designer noted back in 2020 when he
attempted to do this exact same
experiment just before he worked at Riot
now to contrast in Counter-Strike it
takes at least 10 seconds before you're
able to see an enemy and Hell there are
maps where gunfights literally take
place in spawn and this is where we get
to the actual answer and maybe the root
problem for some regardless of how big
Rye decides to make a map it's always
going to feel small unless they switch
to Counter-Strike style of VI phase and
that doesn't even begin to touch on the
issues of claustrophobia I mentioned
that is if you consider it to be an
issue despite having small maps that are
Titan busy Ballard is still a very
popular game so the question if Size
Matters is completely up to what you
enjoy I mean even though many call for
larger and more open maps Breeze is by
far the most disliked map in the game
right now and maybe it has nothing to do
with its size but it's an interesting
coincidence nonetheless with that said I
hope you guys enjoyed our little game
theory session once again when it comes
to finding the actual difference between
Map size is it's not an exact science
and there are plenty of different ways
you can use to come to these conclusions
there's obviously a margin for error and
we ask you guys to consider this while
also inviting you to try this out for
yourselves listen it was a giant pain in
the ass but still super interesting and
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more stuff like it let me know
cheers
so Riot was using the little little
teemos as like a replacement for like a
meter they changed someone's ability
it's it's definitely only five and a
half teemos now it's it's weird you
start using it in real life you're like
oh yeah like I just gonna go pop down
the street to the convenience store to
go how far away is it I don't know 1500
teemos I don't know